you know your personality creates your
personal reality that's it and your
personality is made with how you think
how you act and how you feel so if you
keep thinking the same way you keep
acting the same way you keep feeling the
same way everything stays the same in
your life because nothing changes in
your life until you change right so
turns out if you keep thinking the same
way making the same choices doing the
same things creating the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions or responding to your life in
the exact same way you keep doing that
your biology tends to get more rigid we
fire and wire the same service we
hardwire our brain and they it only
takes a small stimulation or a small
fodder a response to someone or
something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe in myself
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn the secrets to a successful
day enjoy
your biology and your neurochemistry
your hormones your genes everything
stays the same because you're the same
so crisis and Trauma is always the thing
that gets a person to really start
looking at how do I really change right
so so we want to tell people let's not
wait for that let's let's learn and
change in a state of growth and
inspiration so
so if you keep doing those same things
over and over again the middle life
period we we become very very
programmable
so
in order for us to change we have to
become conscious of how we think we have
to become really aware of how we behave
what our habits are even how we speak
now this is a tough one we have to
really look at the emotions that we live
by every single day and and say wow this
this actually could be unworthiness this
could actually be guilt but if you're
too busy with your cell phone and your
social media and you're too busy with
your kids and running around and
everyone your environment can distract
you from these feelings so
my interest is to get people to retreat
from their lives right just for
five seven days and and remove the
constant stimulation in their external
environment that reminds them of who
they think they are as a personality
to separate themselves from the people
they know and the places they go and the
things they do at the exact same time
and then fill their brain with knowledge
and information and then remind them
that they're actually creating their
life
so if your personality creates your
personal reality and that means that if
in order for you to change your personal
reality you got to change your
personality secret number two is learn
to wind down Brandon bershard have you
ever had difficulty winding down at the
end of a busy day and you feel like gosh
I can't sleep because of it or you're
not getting great sleep or you just feel
like constantly frazzled at the end of
the day that you just wish you could
have some sense of Peace amidst all the
chaos of the day well what are you gonna
do I got four ideas for you today the
first one is just you must you must must
must set up a discipline a routine that
you do every night if you're ever going
to make it any better the hopes that one
day we're just gonna you know wander
into a perfect evening where
everything's you know flowers and and
calm and meditation practice and
everything's a perfect yoga studio
around the house that's not gonna happen
unless you have a distinct setup
intention that every night you're going
to follow a routine you know you talk to
parents and you talk about you know
their kids and one of their favorite
parts of their childhood is when the
kids finally got on a routine and when
they got a routine the parents finally
felt like oh at least we can plan a
dinner or at least we know when we're
going to bed it's like as soon as you
establish routines in your life you
start to be able to feel better well the
same thing goes with your evenings your
evenings shouldn't be a hot mess of like
oh we watched the show now let me go
check Facebook and let me do some
Instagram and now let me go do this and
oh random it's like if there's a bunch
of random things at the end of the night
what you're doing is firing off the
dopamine molecule and hormone in your
brain that says I like novelty and all
these new things are firing up your
brain not winding it down so the more
Randomness you have at the end of the
night the less likely you'll sleep well
the more likely your brain will be
activated and want to do more things
it'll be more difficult to chill out so
make sure you to have some type of
routine here's what I recommend the
first point transition from the busy day
you need to have your transitions for
some people that is you come home
you get in the house you go to the gym
you work out then you come back home and
now now there's a break from work versus
home other people they drive to their
house they get into the house they
meditate for 20 minutes 30 minutes 10
minutes whatever it takes other people
take a quick nap whatever it is or even
some other people just take a walk
around the house a couple times and just
focus on releasing their thoughts and
the stress from the day other people
stretch and move whatever it is
you got to have that transition routine
so what is it you need to have something
says I finished the work of the day I'm
going to wind down now and you must
activate a habit for me it's meditation
and a walk that keeps me sane so when I
get home from a day's work even if I'm
working from home but I know I'm done
now I meditate I walk around the block
and I'm in a good place it's just
something I immediately do and I highly
recommend it to you as well next idea
big idea
don't get stuck in social media don't
get stuck in front of screens if you
want to wind down again the way to do
that is to avoid Randomness and Novelty
lots of new things so watching you know
three seasons of a show is not going to
chill you out it's going to create a
little bit of anxiety and dopamine where
you're just like activated you want to
avoid looking as much as social media I
just tell people if you really want to
chill out and like wind down maybe one
show that's okay cool but then read a
book or go for that walk or do something
that removes you from all the like the
the crazy stuff going on especially you
know tweets or Instagrams or scrolling
through news feeds all that's only
firing you up not winding you down
third big idea is make sure you have
something that you do for gratitude
practice
you know one great way to increase your
happiness but also help you calm down is
gratitude so do you have a gratitude
Journal you can do at the end of the
night
do you have a moment where you can just
take and just write down a few things
you were happy for for the from the day
maybe a few things you learned and some
people if you just can you write down a
few things you got to do the next day
just to get them off your mind so you're
not laying in bed going what am I
supposed to do tomorrow and then you
activate all the things you're supposed
to do get that on a piece of paper
somewhere just get it off your brain put
it away and now you don't have to deal
with it anymore
last idea use the environment of your
home to Wind You Down
dim the lights
put on the house music that's calming
music like those candles if you got the
candles drop the temperature down to 68
or 69 degrees so your body gets ready
for bed when you get into bed have your
moment of gratitude where you think and
complete the day where you say this was
a good day
this day is now over I did my best
everything today did pass there's
nothing more I can do to influence this
day this one is done it is complete good
job I'm thankful for it I'm ready for
bed
tell yourself that like give your let
your brain go the day is done
and it releases all this expectation
that your mind wants to have to keep
thinking at night so in bed it's very
important have the have that moment
where you go the day is done I did a
good job
be grateful
go to bed if you can have that
temperature set down make sure the room
is dark make sure you don't have any of
those you know big alarm clocks or
casting light into the room I mean go
for a pitch black dark room at night
it's been proven in every sleep study to
improve your sleep and the depth of your
sleep and Rejuvenation so make sure
pitch black room no lights no sound if
you think you need that Ambiance White
Noise then there's plenty of ways you
can do that but make sure there's no
screen casting light as you do that drop
that temperature 68 69 degrees enter
your sleep from a moment of gratitude
you'll feel a lot better tomorrow you
feel rejuvenated you'll feel ready to go
because if you can wind down well at the
end of the day then the next day when
you wake up you'll be like I'm ready for
the charge life secret number three is
develop an ORS mindset with Jay Shetty
you've done so much and really from what
I observed even you really started in
2000 and I'd say the the sort of
external social media content Journey
started in 2016. yes that is mad that is
mad you've gone from 2016
um making your first content tour in
2022 now just and you're This Global
household name as it relates to content
self-improvement meditation all of these
topics right that's a short period of
time when you look back and you try and
connect the docs as Steve Jobs often did
about how Apple came to be in the little
moments and the little things whether it
was a moment of um good fortune or
whether it was something that you have
spotted in hindsight and your character
why was Jay Shetty successful in such a
short period of time in such a big way
give me the honest practical answer I
don't want anything I want that why why
were you successful so I'm gonna give
you the I'm gonna give you my monk
answer and then then I'm gonna give the
media answer so and then and I live by
both right like you have to you have to
see things as both and that's why I love
my mom answer is I was really fortunate
to meet incredible people when I was
young I met a few people that absolutely
transformed my life I'm eternally
indebted to them grateful to them and I
owe it all to them and so I give all my
success to them you know without meeting
those amazing mentors and those
phenomenal thought leaders and thinkers
who are not famous who are not known who
are not present like they're not they're
not in the social media world they're
not big names or whatever
those people you know those people if I
never met them none of this would have
happened I can see that's the emotion in
your face when you say this yeah I just
I I really you know we we skipped it
earlier but I I just feel like
the gratitude that I have for people who
saw potential in me when I didn't see it
myself
greatest gift you can you kill someone
like I today have self-awareness and I
have confidence and I know who I am and
I I wasn't always like that like there
were tons of years where I was insecure
and
you know I was bullied for being
overweight and I was bullied for being
the only Indian at school and there was
so much like baggage to do with just my
body my language I used and all this
kind of stuff and to to have someone
notice that you may have something
I mean you've had that and that is just
you you like honor that person for the
rest of your life and the best thing is
those people don't even want it so you
know the best thing about all of this is
the people there are not going oh yeah
we did that they're actually saying no
no it's not us like it's you and and I
think that's the beauty of that so I I
have to say that I it's important that I
share that answer not because I'm trying
to give a more strategic answer but I
think it's important because it is a big
part of it and so that would be the
monks that I met would be the coaches
that I met the guys that I met looking
at it from a very practical strategic
standpoint shifting now
my parents forced me to go to public
speaking and drama school when I was 11
years old
and I really didn't want to go because I
was shy I was unconfident I was insecure
about being on stage or being in a
public setting I actually loved acting
growing up I really enjoyed acting and
doing theater and things like that where
I was playing another character but
being myself on stage
that was the last thing I wanted to do
and my parents saw that and they saw
that as something that I should work on
so they forced me and my school to
enroll me in a public speaking course so
from the age of 11 through to the age of
18 for three hours a day three days a
week so nine hours a week for seven
years I went to public speaking school
really for seven years of my life I went
to public speaking school so when I look
back at my ability to communicate my
ability to understand ideas and by the
way public speaking school is
examination based too so we had exams
where they would give you a topic 15
minutes before you have 15 minutes to
research a topic from the books in the
room that they give you because there
was no smartphone at the time when we
were 11 12 years old and you'd have to
create a speech in 15 minutes about that
subject from the books that were in the
room you had to read from a book that
you'd never read before they'd pick a
random page and they'd ask you to read
it out so the examination of a public
and this was at the London Academy of
Music drama and arts it's called Lambda
and that's where I studied for seven
years so that's a very strategic skill
set that I had the time to develop
thanks to my parents you know like
without my parents that none of that
would have ever happened and I think
that's a big part of why people
hopefully appreciate how I communicate
ideas because I've spent a lot of time
understanding communication
but when I was 18 I had nothing to talk
about
so even though I had all these tools and
skills I didn't really use them because
I didn't care about anything so sure I
gave a good presentation at University
and work experience and an internship
but it was never something that brought
me to life
and so then when I met the monks and I
got an opportunity to study The Vedas
which are 5 000 years old and again we
were put through rigorous study we sat
down we had to learn verses we had to
analyze purports commentaries on Ancient
scriptures we had to do comparative
analysis of religions and tradition like
when I was among we were massively
trained in philosophical analysis and
that to me gave me a real strength and
confidence in these ideas so some of the
ideas I present today that may sound
simple they're based on these really
ancient deep truths that I've had the
time to Grapple with with the greats who
really understand them so that to me is
a big benefit I've had where I've had
three years of
complete dedication to studying
philosophy and not just studying the
intellectual areas but the Practical and
the applicable areas as well so thanks
to my monk teachers who gave me that
and then when I went to Accenture
where people were like Jay you're just a
monk why did you go to Accenture I had
to pay the bills I couldn't rely on my
parents and you know my parents are not
wealthy that they could pay my ways
through life and I moved back into their
I moved back into my childhood bedroom
when I was 26. wow living with my
parents with 25
000 18 000 pounds worth of debt and just
feeling that
you know I was like what do I do now and
I applied to 40 companies that would
have given me a job I'm a first class
honors degree student I'm a straight A
student and I was rejected from 40
companies because surprise surprise no
one wanted to hire a monk so everyone
goes what are your transferable skills
sitting quietly and sitting on the floor
like no one needs that so 40 companies
say no to me Accenture finally give me a
shot and I meet someone called Thomas
power and Thomas power I don't know if
you ever met him actually he's
london-based uh he started up like an
early LinkedIn kind of version called
Academy and he was he's very networked
in London in the business space
definitely want to introduce you guys
he's awesome uh and he was brought in by
Accenture to train Us in social media
and train Us in in this new wave of this
new thing that was happening and it's
really interesting because we've talked
about it me and him many times I'm going
to have him on my podcast soon
and I realized I was like you didn't
really teach me much about social media
but you really taught me about breaking
my mindset and he would always repeat
Napoleon Hill you become what you think
about and he'd always tell me that he'd
be like keep saying that to yourself
and I'd keep saying that to myself
remember you become what you think about
you become and then I was like oh what
am I thinking about I'm not thinking
about anything so what am I going to
become nothing and and it was just
really interesting and so he would give
me these little tools and little things
to play with he had another one called
uh ORS which he would say that
successful people have to be open random
and supportive and he'd say that most
unsuccessful people are closed selective
and controlling CSC and he was saying
that when you live in a CSC mindset you
limit your growth but when you live in
an ORS mindset open random and
supportive you expand your growth so
you'd encourage me to be open with
strangers on Twitter it encouraged me to
be open with random people with me at a
conference and he was just training me
in behaviors and mindsets it wasn't like
how to post and what time to post and
this is how you make it wasn't how to
make something go viral like that wasn't
it it was how to engage how to push your
comfort zone how to challenge your fear
why are you so uncomfortable to walk up
to that person and tweet them you know
all of those kind of things and I saw
that my mind just became
open to the ideas he would always tell
me you're an entrepreneur I'd be like no
I'm not no I'm not meant to work for
someone
and so he would keep pushing me until
I'd get really angry with him like you
don't even know who I am only for me to
realize he saw something in me that I
never saw
and then I'd say from there on
that's kind of what gets me to the
beginning of it I would say that for 10
years before 2016.
I was making content and delivering it
in small venues in London so I had an
event in London at University called
think out loud every single week I would
design a poster on Photoshop I taught
myself Photoshop and I'd make a poster
and I would talk about a movie from a
philosophical psychological and
spiritual perspective so I take a movie
like Inception and I'd break it down and
10 students would come every week and
then I teach meditation which I'd
learned from the monks and then 20
students would come and then by the time
I finished University a hundred people
came every single week to hear me break
down and this was no followers the
events were free I Was preparing for
free doing everything for free and I
loved it and I got so much joy and then
afterwards when I was at Accenture I ran
an event in London called conscious
living
and it was just a it was an event which
was probably like five pound on a Friday
night and again I was teaching
philosophy spirituality and meditation
okay five people turned up it wasn't
University anymore where you could go
and deck the halls with flyers and
posters and the common room and the
community area so we'd get like five to
ten people every Friday night paying
five to ten quid just for the food that
we gave and you know the posters that we
made just to cover the costs so for 10
years before I ever made a piece of
content online
I've practiced rehearsed
experimented
grappled challenged these ideas again
and again and again and again and again
without any followers without any money
and without anything else coming from it
apart from the fact that I love it I
love the idea of reading a book and
trying to make it relevant so I would
say that the biggest reason is because
I've done this for 10 years offline
before it ever went online so I've been
doing it for like 16 years and that
doesn't count the 11 year old public
speaking classes also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on on it and start building the momentum
in your life and your business I'll see
you there secret number four is set up
your day with Dean graziosi I've doubted
myself a million times
I felt like an imposter a million times
I've had my own family look me in the
eye and say stop being a dreamer Dean
that's for other people he didn't go to
college we don't come from that kind of
money you'll never be that
they don't say that when I land my own
jet in my hometown and my whole family
gets off my own plane right I don't say
that to be a jerk I don't you don't even
see me do you ever see me post a picture
of my playing on my Instagram I'm not
the guy that holds up money or shows you
in my plane
or my house that's the house of my
dreams I don't do that I don't want
people to follow me because I hold
stacks of money on a on a Facebook ad
right I want people to know me for the
heart I have but I'm blessed to have
more success than I ever could a dream
possible and I get to take care of the
people I love I got to put my own oxygen
mask on years ago and now I put it on a
lot more people than you'd ever know
that's not all I donate to
we've done it in a lot of different
areas and this year I want to donate I
don't know about the feelings you have
but who who felt that in their heart
when I shared what I was able to do
right who in here has a desire to help
other people once you're secure
can I give can I share something with
you and I want to share this today
because it just feels on my heart
I'm going to tell you to be selfish
be selfish
be selfish for the next three years
go get yourself strong go put your own
oxygen mask on
put some money in the bank crush your
company be selfish with your time
be selfish with your income be greedy on
the amount of money you want to make I'm
telling you be greedy be selfish you
know why because if you go all in if you
stop thinking I wish I could do more be
more go all in and make the money get
secure and put your oxygen mask on and
what you can do in five years from now
what you can do in seven years from now
what you could do in 12 years from now
is unbelievable but we need this moment
of us
we need this moment of getting ourselves
so many of us so many of you I see right
now are the most giving people you've
ever any anyone knows you're the person
that gives the most you know what you're
doing you're putting oxygen masks on
everybody else and you can barely
breathe you're out there helping
everybody let's do this let's do this
let's do this and you're barely
breathing you're like here's an oxygen
mask here's an oxygen mask when you need
to hold it to your face
I love the story of Andrew Carnegie
right what did Andrew Carney get a
certain pace of his life you know what
he said I'm going to spend half the
first half of my life making a ton of
money and I'm going to send the spend
the second half of my life giving it all
away
if he would have if he would have felt
guilty if he would have not went for it
he never would have got to the ability
to do the things that he was able to do
with his money I'm telling you be greedy
be selfish
so you could be the least greedy and the
least selfish for the long run
right what is what does Tony always say
and I think he got it from Jim Rohn who
probably got it from somebody else but
we all overestimate what we can do in a
year and we underestimate what we can do
in five
who in here in five years from now would
love to sit down with your family like I
was able to do this Christmas right
after Christmas and say as a family
we have X amount of dollars that we want
to help people
what do you guys want to do
how does that I don't know maybe that
doesn't ring a bell for everybody it
rang a bell for me and my wife's like oh
my God I want to help kids and my my
daughter was like I want to help this
there's too much separation in our world
right now who can we help out to help
Bond our communities Bond the people
become the human race my son had his
idea I'm like okay what do you want to
spend go online find a great company
find somebody that's got five star
rating go come back to the table who are
we going to donate money to how does
that feel what does that do for your
soul right now what does that do for
your heart right now is that bigger than
anything else
but I'm telling you don't do that until
your guy until your mask is on
that's the part we all want to do who
wants to do that who wants to donate
more give more impact more right but who
is I'm not saying you shouldn't help out
now if you don't donate a million out of
10 million you won't donate you know I
mean if you won't donate a dollar out of
ten dollars you won't donate a million
out of 10 million we can do things now
but be more selfish more greedy with
your time your money and all of it right
now put your focus on you but your focus
on being successful because then in one
year three year five years you get to
cut checks and make an influence
make an impact
and that's what I consider being success
success isn't just the money you know I
I have to tell you and do you mind if I
share I hope I hope you don't think I'm
bragging I don't tell anybody I don't
take pictures but 10 years ago 10 or 12
years ago I got invited by somebody now
maybe 15 years ago I got invited
to go on a private plane
I don't know I honestly don't know how
long ago it could have been 20 years ago
and it was something that was really
wealthy
and I was I I'm like I came from a kid
that was in a trailer park and I was
already in business I was already doing
well but nothing like that and I flew on
this plane and it was like you just
drive your car
to the plane you drive right out on the
tarmac
I'm in shock you get out of your car you
take three steps you walk up into the
plane it takes off you land and when you
land your rental cars waiting at the
bottom of the steps I'm like holy crap
this is unbelievable there's food on the
plane there's a bathroom on the plane
it's like this is ridiculous this can't
be possible and I remembered that plane
and I remember thinking myself
I'm buying one of these Someday I'm
gonna buy it after I hit certain
criteria after I saved enough after I
gave enough away I'm buying one of these
and I've chartered since then I've
probably phone mostly private I don't
know 10 years I don't I never talk you
never hear me talk about this look at
this some of us some of you I have a
relationship with for seven to ten years
never shared this because I don't that's
why I don't want you to respect me
because I got a big house and a plane I
want you to respect me from my heart my
feeling and how I got here that's what I
hope I hope I share that with you guys
you see a lot of people go on your
Facebook right now I guarantee there's
somebody holding the half a million
bucks in their hand and someone else in
front of their Lamborghini and someone
else showing off their watch right you
never see that with me I wear pretty
much a great t-shirt today it's a very
special day I have a greenish gray shirt
on it's a special day right here I
digress I was on that plane probably 15
18 years ago I bought that plane a year
ago but was it easy
no have I failed miserably yes have I
doubted myself absolutely have I felt
like an imposter more than you'll ever
know or ever believe
but it's possible
the only thing is we have to stay in the
game we have to find what drives us we
have to keep moving forward we have to
say to ourselves again I know somebody I
see so many incredible people on here I
know the success you've had this isn't
about you not having success success up
until now it's about me hopefully
helping you get to that next level of
success and listen I'm at a place where
I don't like yes I have a plane I have
the I have a beautiful home but I'm not
flashing I don't I drive a Ford pickup
truck by the way guys if you lived in
Arizona and you saw me at a red light I
drive a white Ford F-150 every day I do
not have any other car I don't have
motorcycles I don't buy watches I have a
really nice watch on my wrist right now
if you know watches it's one of the
nicest watches out there it was a
present from Tony Robbins from all the
work we do together or else I'd have a
simple little watch or not wear one at
all so I'm really simple in some areas
and then I get to do the things that I
want but I wouldn't do any of those
things that I want unless I could give
at the level I want to give
net last year I donated more to charity
than ever before in my life
I need to I need a break last year this
year right
so that's my message for today is it's
all possible
dream big
but no we have to put in the work it
doesn't come by accident there's no
magical money machines you don't invent
something today and be rich tomorrow you
don't put a a a a a page up on
mastermind.com on Friday and by Monday
there's a million dollars in your
account it's a process it takes time it
takes effort it takes work it takes
overcoming your fear it takes being
brave it takes being courageous and at
the end of the day I've had an ulcer
before as a kid I've stressed I've gone
broke I've I've been ridiculed I felt
bad about myself I felt insecure
and at the end of the day I would do it
a million times over I get to be with
you amazing people and here's the thing
I know
if I would have stayed and just went
into a job and worked for someone else
even though I knew I had more to give
the world and I'm not saying a job is
bad I'm saying the wrong job right
still would have failed I still would
have felt like an imposter I still would
have been ridiculed all those things
still would have happened but I would
have had someone else with their foot on
my head
so if somebody says to me man be doing
your own thing going for that next level
is scary yes it's even scarier to think
that I have to listen live by someone
else's rules for the rest of my life
think about what's scarier trying and
failing
are living by someone else's rules for
the rest of your life secret number five
is prioritize your sleep with Tom bilyeu
I wake up at 3am in the morning and work
hard and also I am feeling physically
healthy to do the work but after 8 am I
feel sleepy and not able to give my 100
after then please suggest something I
can do to overcome this okay so
I want to make sure that you're getting
all the sleep that you actually need so
if you're waking up at 3am but you're
going to bed at 8 pm then it's fine
that's seven hours of sleep and I would
say the average person probably does
fine between seven and eight hours but
if you need eight you're only getting
seven that's already a problem and if
you're going to bed at 9 or 10 and
getting up at three then odds are you
just aren't getting enough sleep
whenever you're feeling tired one of two
things is true you are not getting
enough sleep or high quality enough
sleep or your diet is off those two
things are going to be the things that
contribute most to whether you feel
fatigued or not there's a third one
which I'll throw in which is exercise
which does a great job of addressing
your mitochondria which are the actual
energy cells uh energy organelles I
guess within your cells and it is
critically important to keep those guys
in shape as well just to make sure that
they can generate the cellular energy
but when you say you wake up at 3 A.M
without giving me any indication I'm
checking it again but yeah there's no
indication what time you go to bed so my
gut instinct is that you're waking up
too early now if that's just naturally
what time you wake up trust me I get it
I spent a very long time just getting
between five and six hours a night and
if I got six everything was great if I
got five one night in a row I was fine
but if I got five multiple nights in a
row then I started to get really tired
to the point where I was once getting my
hair cut and I did one of those head
Bobs thankfully it was
timed well and I didn't end up getting a
huge chunk of my hair taken out but that
was when I realized if I can't sit still
for more than five minutes without
falling asleep
I don't think I'm getting enough sleep
now it's outside the scope of this video
for me to get into what I did to improve
my sleep but there are a lot of things
you can do to improve your sleep
and now I'm actually sleeping more than
I've ever slept in my life because I've
really got that dialed in and I have to
admit it's been awesome to just never
feel not never feel tired because of
course towards the end of the night I
start to get tired but during sort of
peak productivity hours I don't get that
anymore so get all the sleep you need I
don't sleep with an alarm okay I've run
a billion dollar company
I didn't set an alarm then running a
company now grew by 400 over the last
two years I don't use an alarm now so I
work 93 hours a week without using an
alarm so I don't want to hear excuses
that people can't set an alarm you just
need to go to bed earlier now if you
have kids
go to bed when your kids go to bed even
if it's 7 PM do whatever it takes to get
the sleep that you need you need to be a
fiend for your sleep it impacts
everything else hugely important secret
number six is manipulate time with Ed
mylett if the one is bringing this new
way of thinking if the person that
thinks they are the most disqualified is
able to channel that and make somebody's
life better how do they turn that into
like something concrete that they can
articulate how do they turn it into a
habit like what is that process of going
from you know Neo waking up and
realizing that he can do something to
actually dodging bullets I think one of
the things is the way that we approach
time this is something that almost no
one talks about anymore so I feel like
you may be behind
you may actually be behind your destiny
right now like maybe you're not on Pace
in fact I think most people watching
this listening will say I am behind on
achieving my destiny I'm not exactly
sure what it is but I feel like it's
slipping I feel like I'm behind so you
better figure out time differently and
you can bend and manipulate time to your
advantage the most stupid Antiquated
ridiculous concept on planet Earth today
very very well maybe that a day is 24
hours
it's so stupid it's the dumbest thing
ever 24-hour days were contrived when
there were no cars there was no
electricity if I wanted to get you a
message I had to write something down if
I could send it on a horseback hope you
get it that's insane never mind the
internet so it used to take hours days
weeks months years to do can be done now
in a millisecond in the internet or on
our smartphones yet we measure the time
the same way that guy did that's bananas
that is so stupid yet everybody does it
and so I about 25 years ago went I'm not
the most talented I'm not the smartest
and I'm really not and you've had guests
on your show with IQs maybe a hundred
points higher than mine this is the
truth I know a couple of them I had them
on my show how in the world I don't come
from you know a whole track record of
success right I don't have the perfect
upbringing how in the world am I going
to win I got to do things other people
aren't willing to do which I'm doing
that's the one mores and I got to fix
the way I look at time what would I need
to believe about time what would I need
to believe what would the question be
and so my days now are from 6 a.m to
noon that's a day it's six hours and in
that day some days you just chill but in
that day I'm gonna get the amount of
productivity Faith working out fitness
money business you name it in that day
we've all had a morning where we go I
got more done this morning I have in
weeks well why can't you do that every
morning so I measure time I've
compressed and condensed time I bent it
my day is 6 a.m to noon and I'm not
crazy you're crazy for thinking it takes
24 hours just like some dude in a cave
did 300 years ago that's bananas that
you still think that way and it's unfair
that people have taught you this my
second day starts at noon and goes till
6 p.m that's day two but what the cool
thing is at the end of day one this
clock goes off about noon every day bro
and goes what did I just get done what
didn't I do what do I need to be
accountable for what do I need to double
my efforts just like you do at the end
of most days right and then the next day
is 6 p.m to midnight and some of those
are just fun days Sundays I chill right
but some days they're really super
productive what I've done now is I have
changed a manipulated time I now get 21
days a week back that up over a month
I'm gonna kick your butt stack it up
over a year your toast stack it up over
five years my entire life is different
than it would have been otherwise and if
you do this for about 90 of your
traditional days that you think are you
will come back to me and go that
profoundly impacted my life and here's
the other thing that happens the world
responds to you differently when you
value your time like that what is
precious is valuable that's why a
diamond or this watch is way more
expensive than the piece of paper that's
written down there because it's more
scarce when your time when you interact
with the world is slightly more scarce
they respond to you as if you're more
valuable
so you get more accountability more
productivity more fun more joy and the
world flips its response to you all of a
sudden you become more valuable and
precious to people when your time is
different and you'll get thousands more
days in your life and live a much more
Blissful and happy life than the person
only gets 24 hours and secret number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is work on yourself
with sad Guru the most important thing
is to work upon yourself what does it
mean by saying working upon yourself
physically just set up small goals for
yourself for the next few weeks that are
there suppose you're 18 for the last 30
years when the first time when you
became 18 if you did bend down how far
would you go at that time maybe it went
all all the way to the floor today maybe
it's like this just see if you can go
six inches more when you're 18 years of
age how quickly you went up a staircase
today how you are applauding up the
staircase see if you can improve it by
10 20 20 Improvement in the next two
weeks just check your picture when you
are 18 or below how you would stand how
straight you were and now if you become
like this straighten yourself up a
little bit look further back what kind
of smile you had when you were six eight
ten years of age see if you can get 50
of that back on your face all the time
not by simply grinning a plastic smile
but bring that magic back into you if
you cannot do anything fantastic at
least you must be a pleasant piece of
Life on this planet this is something
that you owe to yourself and to
everybody who lives around you this you
must do so set up your own kind of goals
and see it's not difficult I'm telling
you just needs little attention right
now people think they're carrying the
world on their head no no just in case
you are in shirazasana right now and you
take a picture and turn it around it
looks like you're carrying the planet on
your head but that's not the truth
whether or you're on your feet or on
your head planet is scaring you and it's
spinning by itself day and night is
happening by itself seasons are changing
by itself Sun comes and goes by itself
really there's nothing to do these two
weeks are for time for you to realize
everything that is significant in the
universe is happening by itself it's for
you to sit here and enjoy the Bounty of
life just make use of this do not act
like you are running the whole planet or
you are running the whole universe for
that matter you are not it is happening
by itself you're a tiny little creature
who is here for a little bit of time
don't make so much fuss about it to
handle a few years of life do not make
such a big fuss these few weeks you must
come out as a more pleasant and
wonderful human being this is the
greatest thing you can do to yourself if
you sit here this person is a pleasant
experience for you if you are a pleasant
experience for yourself everybody else
will also experience this person as a
pleasant experience what great things
you will do or not do that is subject to
various realities nobody can fix it
hundred percent you must understand our
actions are largely determined by the
times in which we exist suppose you were
here five thousand years ago five
thousand years ago if you were here and
this door virus came to you you didn't
have to do any social distancing because
anyway there was nobody around you even
if you wanted to infect you couldn't
find a person so you need to understand
what we are doing our actions and what
we do and do not do is the times in
which we exist if you are here five
thousand years ago you would not be
writing software you would be doing
something else you would not be doing
all the things that you're doing today
don't think you are doing it it is the
times in the times the times that we are
in has its own weather some smooth
weather some rough weather if you learn
to ride this weather gracefully then
people say you're a success if you
create a problem about every little
fluctuation that happens then you become
a failure in your life if you were a
wave surfer you've seen people surfing
on the waves what is his his dream he
would like to have a tsunami the dream
in a surfer's mind is a tsunami a
hundred foot tall wave riding it that
would be the dream if you know how to
ride it even the tsunami is a wonderful
thing so right now virus it is not going
by itself it is not flying by itself and
getting you it needs us to get somewhere
it's for us to decide whether it goes
somewhere or it doesn't go somewhere
it's our business to see that it doesn't
go anywhere it should not come to you in
case it did happen that it come to you
you must ensure it does not go to
anybody else 100 because this is the
time to show who you are as a generation
of people this is a generational issue
because no more it's a national issue
this is not an issue of a caste Creed
religion no or race virus is quite very
even-handed it doesn't matter what's
your race what's your religion what's
your Caster Creed indiscriminately it is
going to people initially people thought
it will only get the Chinese well now
everybody is realizing virus is not just
interested in Chinese people it is okay
with anybody quite indiscriminate so
this is a generational challenge in
these challenging times will you ride
this wave successfully or will you be
crushed by this can only be determined
by how responsibly you respond to this
whole thing with how much sense or will
we do something senseless and make this
into a massive disaster right now in
India and in most parts of the world
except unfortunately in a few countries
a lot of people don't understand what is
the threshold anymore if you go to an
Indian temple there will be one foot
high threshold it will be little wide if
you are not physically fit you will
little struggle over that but those who
are fit very effortlessly they will
cross this threshold and go right now
it's only a threshold to cross but if we
feed it with irresponsibility this
threshold has the potential to become a
huge mountain that we cannot cross it
needs responsible behavior and
responsible action what does responsible
mean normally most human beings are in a
state of compulsive reaction responsible
action means you consciously respond you
consciously respond to what is in front
of you not compulsively behaved saying
that this is the way I will do things
conscious response because
responsibility means it's just your
ability to respond this is the most
important thing in your life that you
have retained your ability to respond to
whatever comes our way because what
comes our way is not determined by us to
some extent we can decide what comes our
way largely what comes our way is not
determined by us the world decides but
whatever comes our way what we make out
of it is 100 hours this is the time to
show who we are what are we made of Are
We human beings or are we just one more
compulsive instinctive creature this is
what is being tested right now for you
this is an evolutionary test for you see
it is not only for a monkey that some
itch in the body may happen even for you
it happens if it happens you handle it a
lot of people are there you don't
anything when people are not there you
do it like this this is conscious
response this is an evolutionary test
for you you have to prove that you have
become a Human Being Human Being means
one who knows how to be this is a time
for you to show you know how to be bad
people are cooped up together for long
hours people who you claimed that you
love immensely seven days getting very
difficult for a lot of people you must
address this also why has it become so
difficult why is it so difficult to be
with people simply because we have
formed strong opinions and ideas about
everybody including ourselves this is an
important thing that you have to do if
you have to live here as a conscious
human being that is you have no opinions
of any sort strong opinions means you
have concluded about everything in the
world there's nothing to live here for
when you have made conclusions about
everybody and everything including
yourself this means you have destroyed
all possibilities of life life is a
possibility but between the possibility
and reality there is a distance in your
life will you walk the distance or not
do you have the courage and the
commitment to walk the distance or no
this is all the question is about your
life I hope you answer this question
positively because you can address this
in so many ways this happened after the
singing disaster I'm saying after the
classical music concert happened in
shankaran pillai's home she gave up
classical music because of the comment
that he gave then after three days it
was three days classical music next
three days nothing to do so she spent
some time in front of the mirror she
looked at herself when she got married
how she looked and today how she's
looking because of the planetary
influence she was taking the shape of
the globe so she stood in front of the
mirror in the bedroom younger and pillai
was sitting on the bed reading something
she said you know how I have become how
I used to be every year my size is going
up clothing size I'm looking ugly look
at my face everything is sagging my
complexion is gone I have bags under my
eyes this damn Planet it could have been
slim some I just kept reading dude
please say something say something nice
say something that's good about me I'm
completely depressed looking at myself
in the mirror say something nice
something that's good about me looked up
and said well your vision is perfect
something is good about you so this is
not a time to go about picking faults in
each other or even in yourself you just
see how every week you can be at least
10 percent better physically 10 better
mentally ten percent better emotionally
10 better Behavior wise 10 better
relationship wise 10 better one week ten
percent thirty percent increase in
everything you will be quite a fantastic
human being believe me
and one of the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and uh we feel good because we've taken
on this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's um starting to
exercise or eating better or committing
to doing something that's of benefit to
us or even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you are taking to
achieve the results that you want more
and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there's certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results when it comes to
an affirmation uh affirmations can be
powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and
they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift to the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship the fundamental physics of
our relationship to our world uh have
been minced and parceled and in many
cases deleted
from the texts leaving us with a sense
that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility
as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so in
um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen that's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a form
of Prayer
or prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's
still and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community uh as to whether or not I
would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path and when
we begin as a scientist beginning to
understand these relationships gave me
the reason to think differently
and they'll also give me the reason to
test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't if you think
that your thoughts have something to do
with your future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create
Your Destiny and you think sixty to
seventy thousand thoughts in one day and
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before
well then your life isn't going to
change very much as long as you're
thinking the same way and those those
same thoughts lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
exact same experiences and we anticipate
the same feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neural circuitry
our neurochemistry our hormones and even
our gene expression will be equal to how
we think how we act and how we feel and
how we think how we act and how we feel
is called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to be become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them and then we
have to begin to look at the emotions
that we live by every single day
keep us connected to the past and decide
do these emotions belong in our future
so most people are trying to create a
new personal reality as the same
personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 percent of the time running a
series of programs so then sitting and
doing the work had we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new choice but
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance in possibility
so when a person begins to understand
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from the
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy then be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which the community can change brain
or hard coherence they they know how to
do it it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest scans are
people who just have never meditated
before that we're not trying to do
anything they just follow instructions
so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 and not 60 and we do a
week-long event we got a thousand people
or 1500 people and they are all in and
that when they start getting Beyond
themselves that first day or second day
once they start getting Beyond
themselves and that magic starts to
happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting you
want to be a professional baseball
player is that right yeah but then you
got an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big leagues or did
you play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways I don't know you aren't going to
be in The Bigs for I wasn't I played
enough baseball all the guys who ended
up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking before we went
on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were their career
changes I went into a like anybody like
whatever your dream is when the first
one ends it doesn't happen whether that
be a relationship it could be your
marriage it ends it was a dream right or
a business venture or a sport I went
into a pretty good depression and uh and
how old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up depressed I ended up moving
back at home with my parents I was
living in the city I remember I was
living in this sleeping in the same bed
I grew up in with the same teddy bear
the same posters like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after base Poland when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
they think that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
that's right down the street in San
Dimas you're going to be working with
kids doesn't pay anything at six bucks
an hour but you're gonna get this damn
job so show up there tomorrow morning 8
A.M ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh dude yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go look literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like a literally McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yep all boys
it's in San Dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because I I'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask I wanted to compete I wanted to win
I wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little that I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
they don't know and they don't even know
they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want and then they
back away or they go to move and they
don't they go to change jobs and they
don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why fear causes them to stay where
they are
here's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body is in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X-Type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison to walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage now let's go ahead here's the
same person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them and for some
strange reason from Left Field above
bone in comes a y-type idea what is the
y-type idea the y-type idea represents
anything that you might want to do that
you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some strange reason they
know that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this your central nervous system is the
most complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable no on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt
the doubt turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
Beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
ice lived there for the first 26 years
of my life and for the last 50 I've had
a phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
they're experiencing some crazy stuff
they start to doubt their ability we'll
never be able to pay for it they
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and dang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
that's energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
fires remorse
is when you cancel a sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek discipline is your
missing ingredient you've got the heart
you've got the care you've got the
desire to serve you know you could be
doing more you want to do it for the
right reasons you're not just here to
make money you're here to have an impact
in the grow and do amazing things you
know you can do amazing things what's
missing discipline
there's just a lack of follow-through
it's the constant start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me
the only one of the only reasons why I'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post my socials
of how I grew month over month year over
year on YouTube and in the first five
years I had 7 000 subscribers or so
five years in five years in of making
content
7 000 subscribers
a lot of you already ahead of that a lot
of you could get there a lot faster than
me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
in 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be
as slow as me you know I took I took a
long time and I had a lot of issues I
was shy and insecure and introverted and
felt like you had to be you know type A
personality to win and all of these all
of these limiting beliefs all sorts of
issues and you can get there a lot
faster than me but it still requires a
discipline to follow through and do it
and I really think it's one of the only
things that saved me
I remember sitting down at a
um Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my industry it was
in music I'm going to be the next
garyvee in music
and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
let's you know let's let's keep in touch
and see how we do and how we grow and he
posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the host and I told him I was
going to be the next garyvee for music
and he's gonna do keep doing his thing
and and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's a
super talented in music and just better
camera presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff all
of it
the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough it's the it's the lack of
because you're not motivated you stop
and lack of motivation isn't a good
enough reason you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you uh how do you stay disciplined how
do you stay focused when you're not
getting results when you're not seeing
the wins how do you stay disciplined
okay so let me give you a couple things
first is having a really powerful
morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day no
matter how great today is tomorrow's a
new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event or you
watch a video get all inspired and you
expect it to last and then tomorrow you
wake up it's like oh how come I don't
feel the same way as I did yesterday and
then that creates a cycle of
procrastination instead of actually
following through so the morning routine
really matters what is it that gets you
feel inspired motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off
and have a much better day for me
two of the things that I find the most
valuable are in my morning routine one
is music so I put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your
state put on songs that make you move
that make you dance and make you wanna
just change your state because you wake
up tired and no energy like let's go we
gotta demand Excellence from ourselves
and so music is the fastest way to get
your body into a different state
um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day I walk I go
to Tim Hortons I grab a cup of coffee
and spend you know two bucks on it and I
think about my day how do I want my day
to go what how do I want to be
intentional about the day so we're not
waking up like an accident most people
wake up like an accident fall into their
day look at other people you load your
phone you write other people's agenda
for your time and then you don't follow
through and so having that as part of my
morning routine really helps me so what
is your morning routine the most
important thing that you need to do is
the thing that makes you feel important
vibrant that today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happens that's
why I make so many videos too there's
content for you every day if you need me
in your life or you need the people that
I profoundly there's something every
single day for you across my channels so
there's no excuse for you not to get the
the inspiration and the motivation and
the tactics that you need to make your
dreams happen so that's step number one
is have have a powerful morning routine
step number two is create a calendar you
know what's in your calendar I'm making
videos today because it's in my calendar
today's a Tuesday when I'm recording
this and Tuesday is my YouTube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening in
my business uh you know right now we're
we're at um my my wife's parents house
and they're delivering a couch
you see that they're delivering a couch
here
it's a delivering a couch and they're
helping I'm here making content because
Tuesday is my YouTube day you know
there's so many other things I could be
doing right now
if I was left to my own devices I'd say
I have something more important to do I
need to be doing X
but because this has been scheduled in
my calendar I'm going to follow through
and make videos
how have I made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do I'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later I'm still afraid to make
videos why because I want these videos
to be the best I've ever done because I
want to show up with more care more
heart more passion I hope that this is a
video that forces you you know to take
some kind of action I wanted to be the
best one that I've done and so I I'm
mini procrastinate before making videos
on a Tuesday every week I have a mini
mini procrastination the only difference
is my procrastination is you know 10
minutes instead of days 10 days and then
it doesn't happen right and so whatever
you are procrastinating on that you know
is important that you're just afraid of
you put it in your calendar and you
block off time and that allows you the
creativity and the space and suffocates
the excuses
for you not to follow through and then
step number three so one have a morning
routine right that sets you up to create
that gets you inspired makes you feel
like you're important today's gonna
matter two you create a schedule for
when you're gonna do the things
especially the scary things on your list
and then three you have to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your calendar
you said you're gonna do it you put in
your calendar you get it done even if
you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow
or you can change your calendar for next
week but don't trust yourself or listen
to yourself when you're feeling low when
you're feeling overwhelmed and you said
you were gonna do it
because what happens is the next time
you say you're going to do something you
put in your calendar you don't trust it
you're going to follow through because
you haven't followed through the last 20
times so be very careful about what you
put into your calendar and when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline again you've got the heart
you've got the creativity you've got the
passion you've got the willingness to
serve you know you can do more you want
to create an amazing life for yourself
your family the people around you like
you know you've got this thing is you
know you've got this thing I don't need
to tell you this you know that you've
got something amazing inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough you have to stop jumping from
high to high to high and and wondering
why you don't feel motivated today
there's nothing wrong with you this is
normal
discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get 10
more amazing rules from Andrew huberman
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if people out
there think that the moment you start
achieving some success that things are
going to get easier it gets worse there
are more opportunities and therefore
your structure gets disrupted more email
more texts come in more amazing possible
relationships and places to eat and
things to do